زياره الرئيس الصيني لروسيا فتحت الباب
امام التفسيرات والتاويلات بخصوص الهدف
منها وما ترمي اليه في جبه وسيط لحل
الصراع في اوكرانيا وحاملا خطه للسلام
هكذا حاول تقديم نفسه وهو يعلم ما يدور في
مخيلات بوتين الزعيم الصيني راى في
الزياره فرصه للرد على الولايات المتحده
ودعم صورته كرجل دوله عالمي في حين كان
بوتين يحاول تقديم نفسه بانه يحظى بدعم
احد اقوى قاده العالم حتى في الوقت الذي
تعمل فيه الولايات المتحده وحلفائها على
عزله الرئيس الصيني اصطف بقوه مع روسيا ضد
الولايات المتحده لكنهم تنعى عن تقديم شيء
كان يبحث عنه بوتين الا وهو الالتزام
بشراء المزيد من الغاز فالصين تسعى لتجنب
مواجهه عقوبات اقتصاديه غربيه اكثر صرامه
يمكن ان تلحق الضرر بالاقتصاد الصيني
وحين كان شيجيبينغ يجرم بحثات مع
المسؤولين الروس في مادبه عشاء فاخره
بموسكو كان رئيس الوزراء الياباني على بعد
800 كيلومتر يضع اكليلا من الورود في بلده
بوتشا على ارواح القتل الاوكرانيين في
الحرب
فكياف تحظى بتعاطف ودعم كبير من طوكيو
القلقه مما يمكن ان يحدث لها اذا ما اقدمت
الصين على غزو تايوان هي احداث تسير في خط
متوازن غير ان زيارتي الزعيمين الاسيويين
بما لها من رمزيه لم تحدث اي فرق في ميدان
المعركه حتى الان الذي تستعر ناره ولا
تتوقف مدافعه عن القصف بلال البجدين
العربيه